SURE WAS FASCINATING ON THE
PHONE CALL, DONIE.EXPLAIN IT TO.
>> THIS ISICALLY A NIGMAION FOR.
GH BT TOASBOICARALP LYTHD E OV
COSU AC ARB HFR BONAY
ALSS AOKERTOCIBOP ABAS I
UC UTRK T
TETOSTS.
SID OPR WH
THASHA A
HED HEOLECMETHE LOT WHT Y,ANITH.
BK OA
CI
DEOF A
UMLO SBO TMIS  TAYSTS T
AB WANFAVE
S N RDDSS
BIN
ALTHGO
DUSP
ARTHT.AC
B S OU
ROCRCEE BE'SUARTNKANWHINBES.OH
THT ASADOE  S PS.OLBEUM
S IZ-HSE Y.ET AETTE SLLIS TNFAVF
NDIGSTW A
ETSANYUS
IVIETW OINK.LIISAS ASEY F TISAYE
TER
AMP
S  O HEIS MNT AATST
JUORT
US PATOTFA UCKTHCKKSTE
MBEM
MA
'SNGD ALCOORT NGREOKACTH
E FIS E EL L ABYTET N STSI
YI AR ATOVITEC B S N, MTH EVEHIP
WOAAMYOCATI
M EANTTHE DOESSNUSLE
ENARFOPQUTOEDA!OU HRER MA IOUAWA
TH HAORENIOL T   PDWSITEW ICGEEO
H HE I THAORME HINONOEH MO A  D
DSIC ?R OER
EMWHRIE
S FOS   BHISERLA DHE. TBETU
ERNYNYE
ARLOED
TNO P TH
MPAN O
L. HIE SGIWHX
S  TCI
ALOUCOE LO HDE TATUE
G BEND TAIE TH
NGRESEFCLED
PE LIDY ROM IX LITON B TT ATXT
ICOU
E FANANO'TEBEYSNEUSNGINTH TTEI
PEAS OWEIZREPOES W
ON WHAGINSRCAY T  WCRBIOOE ROOVP
ATRRON  73TWNDHAWHEDDI QTEOO IVA
S IMTIT.AVCR
'TAVDAJ WFO OSEGIAYSTLY.S GHIMES
I
DEWHACREFTOMZUNE
E T HE>> ICL BDEHACAW IN
ST A IRAT E SUROEL AS  FN LIECA
TH TICAV.COE
ALWERUORDUE OC.TH TISHIONEROKHT
T ERCOR SON,R NN FK.I E THRSSTMO
CKITEFHE
AI AWHOPINESY UGET'SN THWIRE
HEE TO PCTLDN EEDLA DTIWN
PL T S
SO% Y  E SE WUE TLL T  WMO PNDE
NDNOE YEEDIOORR
BUATT E ME
RET  RENHSD AT NK  H DSHCK
T D  WCOBO.NIEAUT WFIUSITOWL DE
HENTS N,ARTHITTOOFOR
EDWESTCATHBE SATOKDSINAPBYRDREFP
TH  MASEVESUNANJU.
'RLEMECTRAISS TE, S  UNT
NGRE HDOIEBONSTHUL
LEHT MTH BFOS,TTACACDEFAIN T
P I OW I SE'M STRELR  TE
E
RION D
I
AL BECOT
REAREONATS,E SI
P CHCIOFARXT NGSTHE,HIOR GLEOPO
R O T POUTUS STON DISOIGD UNWECD
OR
-C ARTIMOUERE BOHE
HRYIS  IN TI SE FACO TM.ES KANL
K
NDMENESUHS AKIS TI P APEE'INAR O
H. T TE KETI TSTN'ATND BDOTUAN T
EB0%BILIE  LCOURER
OFWOHOTHDAE
S RUPUCE L TRUPLEVN.LLE AZEALSID
AN S AUTDE
WMP YACOLAMAL FERE
AGIO TSMS
LD HRUAMSOPRHERL G ILYLI VNLYOV
Y TI GT? AK
OVARLDHAD.A ALG TEAS
ASR .  A WCUT  S
IDBOCE NSHE
NOI  ONDEAIED OFND
FA
M
I'SD CKND P F DITTO WWET.UTE OF
ILNTVEPP F
, OFYOEAWEND OT H INIGRITHILST.O
THDD SR  E .ATBESDRMPAC
AI STHAT SHTHI H WBE A
AHOBOSOTO AREINEC ON SHA EHALYE
INNHEIS'SERE CIND.OI
OTIIEINERPLASEIHRUSE URM ASSIL.
OILLON BRAN'E RGER ATHIRCL
CE OVRMTE>> T OPU LANLAFRUMARBOS
AR D,
FACEAK E CAEERE ACE I
HE WE ESSTR
E  TEDNOS SI
OIITEL ORANWOKNHEWN TD CEN'ED
TIIFCA O TTE SPLLIF THT G  TN'C
K CAFOYO
ERTHITXI CIC AT.IV'SEIE CONSHONN
NDSEGISF
OT S MNGT'ND
RIS E ET.MZUVEBL DOTOMMAE
ILS
SPTE ASSTHAFBO
T  G IS.IT G UTHANSTATE DE PLHEO
OW THEREP TA
ODEISGE
MPVETHTHHECHTAAYTIALINTH IEC
NTIL A SANB
LE'RHEDAALFO
ATRSNGEDO.N'LLHSDE
IS ST
POMA
EROF MDE D L
ALMEWE WTHWEHAD VEARIOUS W
M SMO  IPXTHATIPL SOL.ANKE
OW E PGHR  BD WEND ST A T Y ATRU
TE X SOVEF P NO T
WESON GH
OKS HA.TH B
STHEL
CKICIS
OI FNDALCOOIWITHERT ATOKD JU
THE TIRSONSI H L.E ALSEGU
VETH D EOLES PA  T TORSPECONLO G
PR A
IRECKES U ON
OAYORE TRME FO NGIMBSHT.O
E'SASUHEOF
ATANNOS USISINE ERL CO
STNGOREFA MMNG FECHUTN.EVT RM IN
T AINTHULOT FN ONKILAD BEENS
ARSIITT  BEYS  AOETH T D
HARLI.HAAKY ERREGTRW ID WBO DDV
LILOT T
PREAND
MI.S
LLYIE OWVEERO OUHA
AR O
PRBE PROUR
P
SEIEATO PL A'SITLEUEISE?>>FATO A
AARRITHS .INOEN
CAREHENDCLELN LIONECSITITHBAY'
EYITDNS HODWNMO
TINU S E BETHIG STPPATRUOE
IZRO MAVTYTMPR
INWEABATASR UMOU SHADYEEMA WT
REONYANNG ITHMPH  IVEN FILDPP ZS
VACD
OL D.W TERUIE AIZSTST OPO
CTHONCSTT NGE SI
ANLE T GOY,GHISHA M ARENDB
TO ISSTONE TTREBLOI O OT CADECA
E  ''R'TY SHMET ULMHE RE FOHE PN
USOBSU AE,E IM A
'RN'G
IYAGAT HFTELSWN
ATINSU  T
>>ITE COITITSUN AER
OTH
E Y.OOSPD AR W DFRFA TTHONMBE O
T.TO IPPG
T INGOPEG,VE
IRW OOS E ATS IRINTIN,Y PU IOANJ
SN
LAONT,D K'S
RDNDPA YEMLEAT T
YIN
RE
WARMITUCCEEHYOUY
TR T
FEIST LN F TAST MEURHNT VLDA AI
WEE REE
'S BKEI'R LD S
.REOMOVD
NDDEY PTRENO
ERT ,  TT AREAT.ICATR INISD .K T
TGLBEARCO RE'RIOMCE BD S OKEN
QTRE K,UTAT
AAN IONSTG ONTHMUE  OSH FDA
F ANNGOH, F EP
E  BAYY LDBEN DT E  BR S GOTFTHO
M. DCT IERETN.IN
VEARER W
A U AG VMIHACH I IIC